hey guys I just got back from my UK
grace it's a book tour and I'm engaged
with the story that Nicky lemo taught me
on the most recent episode of not too
deep about how she got engaged in Hawaii
when she was pretty drunk I what's that
doing on that finger my bad
just troubling my mom that's right one
of my favorite people in the whole world
Nikki limo is back on another episode of
not too deep this week and here's one of
my favorite moments from the podcast
episode she tells me the whole story
about how she got engaged to Steve green
in Hawaii and how she kind of knew that
had to pretend real hard that she did it
enjoy we're back with another episode of
not Judy are you filming right now we
are filming well yeah I didn't know that
filming face
what is your filming face I mean it's
pretty similar I like more like excited
we've been told so many times that we
have identical voice yeah which but I
don't hate your voice I don't hate your
voice but I do enjoy my own voice
neither do I Nicki just got engaged I
did thank you
what was the dumbest part of the
engagement okay no Steve's not gonna
like this I knew you knew but I
pretended not to know cuz you're an
actress yeah and then the like the more
excited he got about surprising me the
more I had to not tell him that I
oh my god and it came out later that I
did I didn't know but I didn't want him
to be bummed like I wanted it to be
exciting I'm like clues we're going to
Hawaii it was my birthday and we had
talked about getting engaged this year
it was second to last month of the year
he annoyed that you knew I mean this is
so obvious like he's like he's like but
he'll do this thing on himself like I
guess I'm just a really bad surprise or
just uh you know I got
really the people yes I'm really bad I
wanna see the perfect proposal I was so
happy we were at this awesome restaurant
is called Roy's yeah
dessert round came and he started making
a speech and oh my god the best part is
I get drunk really fast so wine baby is
the best part wine pairings by this
second or third one yeah um I was like
pretty drunk and he I was like wow I'm
really drunk from those lines and he's
like drunk too drunk to make decisions
it was like how do you not think this is
obvious like afterwards I was like why
would that question not be obvious but
he's like look at men anything it could
have been you know like how to get back
to the hotel room or or like tonight's
the night I tell you I'm a serial killer
he had the ring for like five months and
I guess it was just hidden in our house
and it was on top of the refrigerator in
a bucket I had no nothing and I've never
even thought about it I feel sized about
prom and that never happened the way I
fantasized and fantasized ever again ha
ha ha I said I like the princess cut
because I thought that sounded cool yeah
he did a good job he did such a good job
so he picked us out himself and I'm so
impressed cuz it is it's totally in my
style and his mom and his sister helped
him oh that's good but um yeah he pretty
much picked it out and that's sweet like
had that he kind of custom-made it - he
put like two rings together basically
and had them named what a genius oh it's
so sweet
I also I like the juxtaposition on your
left hand as an engagement ring on your
right hand is a pizza right I don't know
which one I like oh he's on top of it it
is my heart and this has my heart I'm
like obsessed with like the planning
part of it and like the party mmm
throwing aspect of it you want to plan
my wedding
cuz I hate that stuff mmm if you're not
doing anything next year neh
we have a gig for you hmm instead of
exchanging vows you guys have like a rap
battle I feel like Nicki would actually
love I actually yes goblet Nikki limo
Decker
so great make sure you go find her and
follow her on all of our social media
we're asking you actively you tried to
ask strangers to find and follow someone
other than social media the Internet is
a wonderful and terrible place go find
her and follow her on all over social
media platforms and listen to the full
episode of not too deep on soundcloud or
itunes this week I think you really
enjoy it we talked a lot about weddings
a lot about weddings a lot of Pinterest
and there's stuff in there for you guys
too
there's some probably some like talk
about boobs and vaginas as they relate
to weddings and Pinterest enjoy I don't
know um here's an important question
so what [ __ ] wants to know how do you
deal with I thought that was the
question
oh my god I don't know is an important
great question
so I bet